الآن يلقي الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين خطابًا وطنيًا هذا
بينما تواصل القوات الروسية
غزوها لأوكرانيا ، كنا نستمع
إلى الخطاب وحتى الآن يقول بوتين إن هذه
الحرب مبررة في رأيه ويقول
مخالفة لما لدينا  إذا رأينا أن هذا
يسير وفقًا للخطة ،
فلننتقل مباشرة إلى المحرر الدبلوماسي الدولي في CNN ،
نيك روبرتسون ، إنه
يعيش في موسكو ، ما الذي
نسمعه أيضًا من الرئيس الروسي ،
نعم ، كان هناك شيء غريب واحد
حول هذا البث بالنسبة للرئيس
بوتين الذي عادة ما يكون موجودًا بالفعل.  لقد
بدا غاضبًا ، لقد رأيناه ينظر بهذه
الطريقة على مدار الأسبوع الماضي أو نحو ذلك ، ولكن مع
اقتراب نهاية خطابه ،
انتهى نوعًا ما ولم يكن متأكدًا مما إذا
كان قد انتهى ثم جلس مرة
أخرى و  ثم أخبرك
أنك تعرف الجمهور هنا أن
الحرب تسير على ما يرام ، كل شيء على المسار الصحيح ، كل شيء على ما يرام ،
لكنني أعتقد أن
هدف هذا الخطاب كان كله حول
محاولة إبقاء روسيا  الجواب على المسار الصحيح
معه ومع حربه تحدث عن
إعطاء ميداليات بعد وفاته لأولئك
الجنود الذين قتلوا 498
وفقًا للجيش الروسي الذي تم
الإعلان عنه بالأمس ، لذا هنا لديك
يومًا بعد سبعة أيام فقط من الحرب
بالإضافة إلى تسليمها.  أوسمة بعد وفاته
بالاسم وتقول إن أي
عائلة لجندي قُتل
ستحصل على 65000
أي عائلة من أي جندي مصاب ، ومن
المفترض أن هذا الجندي سيحصل على أربعين
ألف دولار أيضًا مع ذكر أنه
سيكون هناك تأمين للجنود
يفترض أنه يقصده في الطب  السياق
هنا ، لذا يحاول بوتين حقًا إبقاء
الدولة على متن الطائرة حتى أثناء قوله
إنها تسير على المسار الصحيح ،
وبالطبع نرى هنا أنه ليس